la onu ha advertido que en el 2050
podría haber un desabastecimiento
generalizado de agua qué medidas cree
usted que deberían tomarse en la cob 26
para intentar evitar este panorama
hola buenas tardes muy contenta de poder
estar conversando con ustedes el día de
hoy lo primero que tenemos que entender
es que el debate desabastecimiento de
agua está directamente relacionado con
los impactos que está teniendo la crisis
climática por lo tanto la primera medida
es que los países toman en serio el
llamado a asumir compromisos esto
significan contribuciones nacionales y
apuntan a mantener la temperatura del
planeta en 1,5 grados y esto significa
poder realmente traducir esto no
solamente en anuncios de los presidentes
sino que poder reflejar eso dentro de la
negociación lamentablemente con los
anuncios que los países han hecho hasta
el momento estamos avanzando en una ruta
de más de tres grados sí y al mismo
tiempo necesitamos de manera urgente
proteger aquellos ecosistemas que nos
permitan tener más agua estamos hablando
de los bosques estamos hablando de los
glaciares estamos hablando de los
humedales y eso debe quedar reclame
reflejado también en los compromisos en
materia de adaptación la protección de
los ecosistemas que nos van quedando no
solamente nos ayudan a disminuir las
emisiones sino que también a enfrentar
los impactos el cambio climático y eso
es algo quienes hemos ver reflejado en
las negociaciones mismas ves el texto de
esta cumbre de cambio climático bueno
usted nos habla de la importancia de
proteger los ecosistemas que tengan agua
y previamente en otra entrevista
diferente con un medio distinto usted
había dicho que para mantener la
temperatura por debajo de los 101 105
grados adicionales era necesario
apostarle el 100 por ciento a las
energías renovables que cree usted que
debería pasar con las termoeléctricas de
américa latina'
así es esto es algo que ha mencionado la
ciencia debemos ponerle un fin a los
combustibles fósiles recordemos que la
generación de energía en base a
combustibles fósiles no solamente está
obsoleta sino que genera enormes daños
en los principales zonas de
latinoamérica donde hay termoeléctricas
y gran contaminación están literalmente
envenenando a las personas día a día es
por eso que tenemos que avanzar hacia el
cierre de las termoeléctricas partiendo
por las termoeléctricas a carbón hay
países que han hecho compromisos pero
que no son suficientes el caso de chile
que se compromete a abandonar el carbón
al año 2040 es decir las comunidades que
viven en las llamadas zonas de
sacrificio por el carbón tienen que
estar condenada a 20 años más de esta
contaminación y luego tenemos que hacer
una transición completa para eliminar
los combustibles fósiles y poder avanzar
las energías renovables américa latina
tiene un enorme potencial era energías
renovables esto puede ayudar a
reconvertir las economías también para
eliminar los combustibles fósiles y esto
se debe ver reflejado también en el
texto de lo que lo que hemos visto es
que los países lo que han hecho son
presiones para eliminar aquellos
mensajes
de la ciencia que van en línea con el
modificar la manera en la cual estamos
teniendo y abasteciendo nos de energía
del abandono de los combustibles fósiles
es urgente porque los cambios que están
registrando nuestros ecosistemas y
nosotros como sociedad van a un ritmo
demasiado acelerado